all right
good morning everyone
i'm joined today by dr kieran moore
ontario's chief medical officer of
health and matt anderson president and
ceo of ontario health
i would like to thank both dr moore and
matt for their partnership throughout
the pandemic and their commitment to
serving the people of ontario
earlier this month the province
reintroduced time limited public health
measures in response to the highly
transmissible omicron variant
at the time we were facing an alarming
increase in hospitalizations
unlike anything we had experienced
during previous waves of of the pandemic
with the number of new hospitalizations
doubling every seven days
percent positivity was almost at
31.9 percent
nearly 10 times higher than when omicron
was first detected in our province
omicron is testing health systems across
the world and our province is no
different
simply put
more action was needed to prevent our
hospitals from becoming overwhelmed
particularly as our hospitals faced
staff shortages due to the rapid spread
of the virus
ontario is fortunate to have world-class
hospitals and frontline healthcare
workers who for nearly two years have
been steadfast in their commitment to
providing high quality care to both cova
19 and non-covet patients
i want to thank those individuals for
their continued dedication and bravery
during these truly unprecedented times
when our government announced the
introduction of measures to blunt
transmission of omicron we were clear
that they were time limited
we know that people and businesses need
certainty on what the future looks like
and as the premier mentioned yesterday
we will be providing more clarity later
this week
as a first step we want to be clear
about some of the data we are using to
inform the chief medical officer of
health's recommendations
and cabinet deliberations
ontarians should have the same
understanding of the situation as
government does
particularly in light of the situation
and how quickly the situation has
evolved with the omicron variant
i'll let dr moore and matt speak to some
of the details in a moment but i want to
assure ontarians that we're starting to
see glimmers of hope
the sacrifices you are making now have
meant we are beginning to see signs of
stabilization
omicron cases are expected to peak this
month
with the peak in hospitalizations and
icu admissions to follow
new hospitalizations are slowing and are
now doubling closer to every two weeks
experience in our hospitals has
confirmed omicron is not as severe as
delta
with far fewer patients requiring
intensive care than in previous waves
despite much higher rates of
transmission in the community
over the coming days and weeks we expect
these trends to continue
giving us more confidence as we plan for
what comes next
but i do want to be clear
february will continue to pose
challenges especially for our hospitals
as people continue to require care for
covet 19.
but our goal has always been to ensure
capacity is there to provide care for
those who need it
given current trends we are increasingly
confident in our ability to do so
ontarians have also continued to make
good use of this time by rolling up
their sleeves
and we are leading the country in
getting boosters into arms
our government issued a call to action
to get as many vaccines into arms as
possible and team ontario has answered
that call
the capacity is in place and
appointments are available through four
ontarians who want to get their vaccines
sooner
i continue to urge everyone to get their
first
second and booster shots as soon as they
can
another exciting positive step is the
recent health canada approval of
paxlovid an antiviral medication
we are expecting to receive very limited
supply of just over ten thousand courses
of treatment for january
we are working with ontario health to
distribute this supply at a number of
sites across the province as soon as
it's received helping to further protect
our hospital capacity by prioritizing
those at highest risk of severe outcomes
so i know that this has been a very long
and difficult road for the people of
ontario
you have shown remarkable resolve in the
face of considerable
adversity each time you've risen to the
challenge
and i have no doubt that you will do the
same now
we will
we will get through this together
ontarians remain committed as we always
have by taking a cautious and gradual
approach
guided by the evidence
today we want to provide some of the
data that we are using to help inform
the cautious approach that will guide us
over the weeks ahead
before i hand things over to dr moore i
want to respond to some extremely
concerning reports that some doctors are
spreading misinformation about vaccines
at a time when it's never been more
important for ontarians to have
confidence in the safety and
effectiveness of vaccines
this is unacceptable
i will be sending a letter to the
college of physicians and surgeons of
ontario urging them to do everything
that is possible to put an end to this
behavior
they should consider all options in
doing so including reviewing the
licenses of physicians found to be
spreading misinformation
this behavior takes away from the
unceasing efforts of the vast majority
of physicians who are working to protect
us all
i want all ontarians to know that our
vaccines are safe
and effective
they're the best protection you have
against covid and omicron
please please get vaccinated as soon as
you're able
thank you very much and i will now turn
things over to dr moore
thank you minister elliot and good
morning everyone bonjourne tus
as the minister just indicated the
sacrifices ontarians have been making
are having an impact
i'm starting to have more hope and
cautious optimism
for the first time in several weeks the
number of hospitalizations and cases in
the intensive care unit is increasing at
a slower pace the severity of omicron
coupled with the protection offered by
vaccines has meant that the length of
stay for hospitalizations is now five
days compared to nine days for the delta
variant
we are also now starting to see our pcr
test positivity stabilize between 20 and
25
when considered alongside other data we
we track such as capacity and length of
stay in hospitals in icu this is an
encouraging sign
that we may
may be reaching the peak of omicron
transmission in ontario in the coming
weeks
while this gives me more hope we must
remain cautious and humble in the face
of this aggressive virus
and the most important thing we can all
do as the minister has said is get
vaccinated
prevention is the key with additional
public health measures currently in
place our our public health and
healthcare partners have taken advantage
of this time to get even more shots into
arms in just over two weeks thank you to
all of our vaccinators over
and fifty thousand ontarians have
received a first dose
and one million doses have been
administered in total
more than 725
000 people have gotten their booster
dose and ontario is leading the country
in third doses administered
5.7 million ontarians have stepped up
come forward and received their third
doses
77
of our over 70s
are now protected
better with their third doses so thank
you to all those that have come forward
and thank all the vaccinators across
ontario
vaccines remain the best tool to protect
ourselves against severe outcomes of
covet 19
including hospitalization and admission
to intensive care
currently 50 percent
of the individuals in the intensive care
units across ontario are unvaccinated
and yet the unvaccinated only make up 10
of our population
this alone demonstrates the positive
protection that vaccination can provide
against these severe outcomes and the
benefits of vaccination against severe
outcomes have been shown across all age
groups that is why i continue to
strongly encourage the parents of our
youngest eligible ontarians those 5 to
11 years of age to come forward and get
their children vaccinated
currently
and thankfully 50.4 percent of children
have received their first dose but we
want to see that number continue to
climb
and for parents to continue booking and
coming for their second doses the
pediatric pfizer vaccine for children is
safe
it's effective and it provides strong
protection against covet 19 and its
variants
boosters are incredibly important and as
a reminder it's very important for those
who are older in our community who have
any any underlying medical disease for
our health care workers and pregnant
individuals and those that are
immunocompromised
it cannot be emphasized enough just how
critical vaccination is to reducing our
personal and community risk and
protecting our health care system
so thank you ontarians for embracing
vaccination and for making the
sacrifices that you have over the last
several weeks
together we've made an impact and we've
made a difference
and together these efforts will chart
our path forward towards a safe and
gradual
reopening we must stay cautious we must
stay disciplined and never underestimate
this virus as we look to take the small
steps forward thank you and i'll now
pass it over to matt anderson
all right good morning
thank you minister elliot uh thank you
dr moore i'm going to take a few minutes
just to provide a brief update on our
health system and our capacity and some
of the challenges of this wave
overall as you've already heard from the
minister and dr moore we are seeing some
encouraging signs
but we remain in a very challenging
environment and we're not out of the
woods yet
just to highlight a few of the measures
that we're monitoring um that do point
uh to some hopeful signs
as you've heard from dr moore we're
seeing relatively fewer people requiring
intensive care
over the last few weeks the total icu
occupancy has remained relatively
constant
today we have a total of 571 covid
positive patients in our icus compared
to a high of just under 900 at the peak
of wave 3.
we're also seeing that patients have a
shorter length of stay
in our icu
and this is helping to limit the overall
rise of
the numbers in our icus
on the acute care side where we have our
our biggest challenge is in our ward
beds or hospital beds we currently have
more than 4 100 coveted positive
patients in our hospitals
this is the highest total of
hospitalizations we've seen throughout
the pandemic and over the last seven
days
fortunately we are starting to see some
slowing of that growth
as noted by dr moore it's still growing
but the rate that is growing each day
seems to be slowing
these are encouraging signs
however it's important to remember that
even while with these key measures are
trending in the right direction
we don't feel that in the hospitals we
don't realize these benefits for a
number of more weeks
we still have hospitals that are under
very challenging circumstances as we
deal with these rising numbers
as the minister has indicated our health
system
will likely continue to experience
challenges through february
a particular unique challenge of this
wave has been related to
sick call
as it relates to kovid in many of our
healthcare settings
it's affecting all sectors and continues
to add strain on the remaining staff
this includes our community care centers
our community support service
home care
and hospitals across the province
primary care has also been affected
however they continue to do amazing work
to support our vaccination efforts
and we are seeing that they are
continuing to try to grow their
in-person
supportive care
thankfully we are seeing some signs
that absentee due to covid may be
stabilizing
we do have a number of agencies across
the province saying that they're
experiencing that they now have more
staff coming back
then are on sick call that day
an encouraging sign but again something
we're going to have to watch
we continue to face pressures in some of
our hot spot hospitals
we do have a number of hospitals that
are operating at over 100 percent
occupancy in their ward beds
through our regional incident management
systems we have been transferring
patients to try to load balance and to
try to ensure a safe duty of care for
all patients who are coming into all
people who are coming into our hospitals
last year last week alone
we did over 100 transfers
in other ways
as in other ways we are using the full
resources of our provincial health
system this has been key to our efforts
to ensure ontarians get the care they
need
we recognize that with the difficult
decisions that we've had to make over
the last few weeks this has had a
tremendous impact on all of us and on
our families most of us if not all of us
know someone who is waiting for care
these are difficult choices through this
phase of the pandemic
along with our ministry and government
colleagues we remain focused on
addressing delayed care as soon as we
possibly can
in closing i just want to echo the
minister's thanks to our health care
workers
our system has been under strain for
almost two years now and yet our front
line has not wavered in their dedication
and commitment to patients
thank you to our health care providers
across the entire health care system
our community care primary care
long-term care home care and acute care
hospital workers
all of you have continued to do your
part to keep our system running and
caring for patients thank you again for
the opportunity to address you
operator over to the first question
please
your first question comes from allison
jones with the canadian press please go
ahead
oh hi thanks very much uh my first
question is probably best put to
minister elliot
um we're here hearing the message today
obviously that there's some very early
positive signs some glimmers of hope
as you say
you say that there's a positive
announcement coming later this week on
restrictions is that perhaps a little
premature to talk about when schools are
reopening this week and that could
potentially
add another wrinkle to this
could it possibly drive up transmission
in a way that erases some of these gains
allison i'm going to refer that question
to to dr moore to speak about
what
challenges we're facing with the opening
of schools and
nothing specific about what next steps
will take but just to speak about the
issues you've just raised
hi allison thank you for that question
well i am excited to have schools open
and i hope all parents
understand that we're opening them with
as many layers of protection for the
students
as possible including daily screening
the rat test should be able to be
distributed now that the schools are
open after the snow storms
and the mass that we provided so we have
as many layers of protection as we can
in the school setting to reduce the risk
of transmission uh we'll clearly be
monitoring that situation
i i am looking forward to the government
announcement i am confident that it will
be phased it will be gradual it will be
based on data
and will follow the prudence that
they've done in the past
on that staged and phased reopening we
will continue though to monitor any
risks of increased transmission in the
community
as a measure schools certainly haven't
had a significant impact on transmission
in the past and i do believe the
measures we put in place should minimize
them
as best we can as a society and we've
together made schools as safe as we can
and again happy to have students back in
the classroom for their mental physical
social and educational well-being
follow-up yeah thanks this is also for
for you dr moore um i had asked you last
week about kovid deaths in the province
and unfortunately we've seen
another very high number
of deaths reported today and i'm
wondering if you're able to share any
more information today on
what's leading to this whether
it's still the tail end of delta
infections or if omicron is driving this
is this
mostly
you know is it based on vaccination
status is it based on age group is there
anything more you can give us to help us
understand what's happening well i i
applaud your question because i had the
same questions myself and we are
continuing to work with all of our
partners to get as best data to
ontarians as possible so we're reviewing
the death certification process we're
reviewing whether the death is causative
or associated with covet 19 we're trying
to clarify if individuals have been
vaccinated or not
death and i hate
talking statistically about death i know
each individual is a member of someone's
family and and i'm absolutely regret um
the deaths but
statistically i do believe
that a significant proportion of the
deaths are related to delta as we all
remember we had that delta rise at the
end of december
and then omicron took over delta is a
much more severe pathogen had a higher
death rate associated with it
and
we're seeking to clarify
and differentiate omicron versus delta
so bear with us
these are often
difficult
elements to tease out
across a health system to be able to
give the best and most reliable data to
ontarians and decision makers but if you
you ask me i do believe that the vast
majority are related to delta because
as you know the someone gets admitted to
hospital then often they'll get
transferred to the intensive care unit
then
they if they deteriorate they get
intubated
to be able to maintain
oxygenation levels uh and and then um uh
they either pull through or sadly a
significant proportion die uh and that
process often takes four to six weeks uh
and we're just trying to get you uh and
all ontarians better data in in that
regard
next question
your next question comes from
richard southern with city news 680.
hi minister uh the premier has said and
i think dr moore kind of said the same
thing that we're going back to other
levels of restrictions it sounds to me
like there's already a plan in place can
you number one give us any idea what
that plan is today but number two
what data is this going to be based on
we haven't seen any data from schools
because they just went back in session
today how can you make a decision
minister about lifting restrictions when
we have seen no data from schools
well we will have more to say
about
any movement with respect to
restrictions later on this week
but
i would say with respect to schools we
are very pleased that the students are
going back for all the reasons indicated
by dr moore and that there's very little
evidence that there's
high transmission just in schools
themselves we know that there's high
levels of community transmission right
now but in schools themselves
as students go there they have been
made as safe as possible with the the
heppy filters with the hepa filters with
the
number of rapid tests that are going
into the schools with the n95 mask being
available for teachers and child care
workers we are taking every step
possible to make sure that when our
students go safe because safely back to
school that they will remain healthy
follow-up
you mentioned maths minister we've heard
from a number of parents who say the
masks provided to students don't fit
correctly i'm wondering if you can speak
to how important a a properly fitting
mask is number one number two you say
icu uh uh occupancy has remained
constant i'm wondering if dr moore could
speak to if that has anything to do with
the high death rate 60 more ontarians
losing their their lives to coven today
okay well thank you i'll refer that
questions to dr moore then
so the first question in regard to mass
quality um the mass that we've provided
the three ply masks uh to to students
across ontario um are to provide an
alternate for students if they uh
want to use
those masks uh and um you're absolutely
right a key component is that they fit
well so one would hope uh in the
educational sector uh they're helping
students uh ensure that the mass are
appropriately fitting uh and uh all
masks have to cover the nose right down
to the chin uh we should wash our hands
before wash our hands after uh and uh
it is the best fitting mask
that all children should be wearing so
if that's a quality assurance issue that
we have to follow up with absolutely we
will
in partnership with the ministry of
education in terms of the icu one of the
most important markers that we've been
following and sadly you're absolutely
right a certain proportion do succumb to
covid19 has been the length of stay
and the length of stay
had a peak
many
months ago
in the 20s
20 days which gave us an understanding
of the complexity of care that some
individuals required in multi-organ
failure that some individuals
had with kidney failure and or bone
marrow suppression
and or liver injury
so
now though we're seeing a much different
picture the length of stay is uh coming
down it's stabilizing at six and seven
days which tells me we're providing the
right care to the right ontarians at the
right time
and i do think with omicron we'll see
less lethality that we're seeing that
trend as we compare to previous waves
because
the virulence is less but some
individuals still need
intensive care
services and mechanical ventilation
especially if they've got any underlying
illnesses and hence our mantra of please
if you've got any underlying illness no
matter what age 18 and above please come
forward and get your booster dose it's
very important as a marker of prevention
against severe outcomes
so i hope that answered those two
different questions
next question
your next question comes from erica
villa with global news please go ahead
thanks so much for taking my question uh
this question is for dr moore you've
previously said that you wanted to see a
plateau uh in terms of numbers is there
a certain decrease or a number that
we're looking to to see within
hospitalizations
before really initiating that plan here
in ontario and are you also planning on
ramping up testing for that as well so
it is a series of data points that we're
watching so
a key metric is the total number of
patients with causative
admissions to the intensive care unit
and
require and or requiring mechanical
ventilation and their length of stay
and the total number of patients that
are causative in hospital from covet 19
and their length of stay so that the
ability of the health care system in
ontario to care for those that have the
most severe illness those are key and
important metrics to also we still have
55 000 ontarians that are getting pcr
tested every day
and thanks to all of those that are
coming forward to our assessment centers
we're looking at the percentage of those
tests that are positive it's it went up
to 30
percent 31
it's come now to the 20 to 25 range so
that's a marker of the percentage of
tests that are positive that's a again
another key metric the other key metrics
we're watching certainly
is the health care capacity uh in
ontario so we knew many workers would be
absent uh due to themselves getting
coveted 19 principally from the
community
and we needed to ensure that all
ontarians would receive care at the
right time at the right place by the
right staff
and as matt has mentioned to us we're
starting to see a health care
provider
stabilize and we are able to provide
care despite 100 occupancy in some of
our settings
and the number of outbreaks in
particular in our long-term care sector
is is another key metric
because
patients have to move across our system
from the acute care sector to community
hospitals and then often back to
long-term care sectors
and the more facilities that are in
outbreak the more difficult it is to
provide the right care at the right time
so i hope you're realizing it's not one
number it will be a judgment based on
all of these different metrics by
government of when to safely and
cautiously reopen
and i do believe we've done so well in
the past
and sometimes we've had to stabilize at
one phase of the reopening and go longer
sometimes we've gone a little shorter
but we've always followed the data and i
hope that i've given you a brief
synopsis of some of the key metrics that
we're following
follow-up thank you for that my next
question is for the minister for my
colleague karen lieberman uh minister
ontario has uh pledged to provide n95
masks for education staff and rapid
tests for uh to staff and students will
this be enough coupled with other
measures like the hepa filters to keep
schools open during this latest wave
well we i i will say that we've taken
every step that is possible to protect
our students and staff and and daycare
workers as well having the hepa filters
is really important we're putting
seventy seven hundred thousand we're
adding another several thousand we are
uh distributing the uh rapid antigen
tests to teachers and students so that
they can
monitor these tests will be supplemented
as time goes by
we're
we've increased the number of cleaning
and disinfecting processes that we're
taking so we're doing everything that we
can to protect our students because it
is really important for their mental and
physical health as well as their
educational needs for them to be back in
school
next question
your next question comes from john
mcgrath with tvo please go ahead
good morning minister and uh
dr moore you've both repeatedly said
that you're doing
everything you can to protect students
as they return to school but i mean
that's not true right the the uh
co-vaccinations are not mandatory for
students the way they are for
other
vaccines uh the immunization of school
pupils act has not been
amended and even if the government
doesn't want to make that a general rule
across the province
local mohs who have asked for that power
can't do anything until the government
amends that regulation they
they don't have the power to do that so
i'm wondering if the minister could
explain why the government continues to
tie
local medical officers at hand and deny
them this
important public health tool
well many parents are taking advantage
of the fact that their children age 5 to
11 can be vaccinated
we have over
a 50 percent a number of children that
have been vaccinated with their first
dose already and more are coming forward
but with respect to the particular
regulation i will
refer that to dr moore please
i'll i'll just remind once again that
the immunization of student pupils act
is not mandatory immunization it's
mandatory reporting of your immunization
status and in the ispa
you you must provide us with
in public health for a set number of
vaccines whether your child is immunized
if you haven't had them immunized will
provide an educational module or you can
provide a medical
exemption
or
some other type of objection based on
religion or philosophy or beliefs
so we don't have mandatory immunization
policies in ontario um we are working
with their health units to ensure that
they can get line listings
electronically of
the classroom so if there is activity
within a school
they'll know the immunization status and
they'll be able to provide advice to the
school boards
and to ensure that they have the data at
their fingertips
certainly over time we will be reviewing
as we do for all measures within the
covid
our policies our protocols and our
procedures
but i do believe
health units have tools at their
disposal to be able to
consult on a regular basis and support
the opening of schools
and have data as they need it
follow-up
in terms of the testing both the the
positivity has come down a little bit
but the volume of tests conducted and
the backlog
are both down substantially from where
they were several weeks ago
pardon me if i
missed something specific on this but is
the government intending to
expand eligibility for pcr testing again
so thank you for that question so as of
today the report we've been processing
53 000 tests a day so thank you to all
ontarians that have gone to assessment
centers and guided testing our turn
around time we're still not a perfectly
happy with the turnaround time of 64
percent after two days
that
sometimes will slow down the ability of
public health to respond to an outbreak
or to a scenario to be able to minimize
harm so we're absolutely working on
improving the turnaround time with that
53 000
tests a day
we had a high of 58 000 on january 7th
so the system is working
in terms of being able to test those
that meet the eligibility criteria and
as we've said before we all have to
remain flexible and adaptive
if we see an increased demand for
certain populations to have access to
pcr timing we have to make sure it's
timely
that it will enable rapid decision
making by public health for treatments
and or for isolation or quarantine and
high-risk congregate settings especially
our long-term care facilities our
retirement homes
our shelters
and in our hospital sector so those were
our priorities we have a framework by
which we will approach opening uh
eligibility for further pcr testing
based on need based on access for
treatment uh and based on high-risk
populations so
we're working diligently and thank you
to all laboratories
they are having the same uh
sickness calls that other agencies are
happening i know they're working
diligently to try to process these tests
as quickly and as efficiently as
possible and thank them for all their
work i know our turnaround time will
improve uh in the coming days uh
and it was a difficult beginning of
january for most organizations and
businesses across ontario and this
clearly reflects it so to to summarize
and to finally answer your question
we're absolutely reviewing all criteria
on a regular basis of access to pcr uh
and ensuring that people get the right
test at the right time i'm i'm happy
that we've given out 3.9 million rat
tests
to parents
of children
and that they can
no longer have to do the drive down to
an assessment center
have to wait for a pcr result but can do
the test in the quiet of their home with
minimal
travel time required and have the answer
within minutes so
thank uh parents for their patience as
we distribute the rits and we will
certainly as the minister said
supplement those rats with additional
tests
on a regular basis to ensure all parents
and children have access to keep our
schools safe
last question
your final question comes from rob
ferguson with the toronto star please go
ahead
hi rob
hello everyone i'll direct this to dr
moore um last thursday when you were
asked about reopening you said you
couldn't guarantee that
january 26 would be a good day to get
rolling on it has your opinion on that
state changed
or is
is there still some caution there about
january 26th
hi robert i i do believe this is a
government decision uh the premier i i
believe um will be um
making a statement on this um we will be
continuing reviewing data to inform that
decision and i can't make any
foreshadowing of
of that statement
follow-up and this is the last question
okay we all know what the government
decision but we also know also all know
that you're the one who makes the
recommendation so i asked you
what is your opinion of that date and
especially in light of the fact that
schools are getting most schools are
getting
back into in-class learning a little bit
later than expected
well i i do think it's two weeks uh that
date is roughly two weeks after the
start of school even though with the
snowstorm we'll have to be a little more
cautious and monitoring
we're monitoring all pediatric
admissions to hospital all pediatric
admissions the intensive care unit we're
tracking that very closely as well as
the pcr test positivity in children to
have a key metric of any increased
transmission or risk within the school
settings and we'll be informing
government of any trends in the coming
days to enable them to make an informed
decision on the reopening
of ontario